hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions here's a
fun geometry problem from Indonesia
inside rectangle ABCD there are right
triangles
AED and B FC as shown in the picture
note that point F is located along de if
a E is equal to 7
edie is equal to 24 and B F is equal to
15 what is the length of a B I think
Raul from Indonesia for sending me this
problem can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution so
before I go over a solution I want to
admit that this problem stumped me for a
long time so here are some of the things
I tried before I could figure it out
I first considered the altitude lengths
of these triangles while I could figure
out the lengths of these altitudes I
then saw that there would be overlap
between the altitudes so that would not
lead to the length of a B I then
considered extending other lines in the
diagram but no matter what I tried I
couldn't figure out how this would lead
me to the length of a B so at this point
I was pretty frustrated and I was stuck
I started searching for similar problems
online and I still couldn't find
anything so I was about to submit this
problem to a forum to ask for some help
and I'll mention that if everyone tried
this hard I'd get much fewer emails
asking for help especially for
well-known maths results people often
email me thinking that math problems are
easy but even for me I usually have to
try many different methods to figure out
a problem unless I already know it but
usually I have to go
through all of these steps so I was
about to give up and then finally it
struck me huzzah I realized a way to
solve the problem so let me go over the
solution step by step the first thing is
we'll figure out the length of ad since
AED is a right triangle an ad is the
hypotenuse we can solve for its length
using the Pythagorean theorem ad is
equal to the square root of the quantity
7 squared plus 24 squared which
simplifies to be 25 you might also
remember this because AED is a special
right triangle if you have legs 7 and 24
the hypotenuse will be 25 next we'll
have that BC is the opposite side of the
rectangle so BC is equal to ad is equal
to 25 now we'll solve for the other leg
of BFC CF is equal to the square root of
the quantity 25 squared minus 15 squared
and that simplifies to be 20 you can
also do this because you would notice
that B FC is a 5 times scaled version of
a special 3 4 5 right triangle so that
would simplify the calculation a little
bit but either way we have that CF is
equal to 20 now we'll draw altitude GF
in triangle B FC by similar triangles
the ratio of the shorter leg of this
right triangle to the hypotenuse is a
constant so we have the following ratios
the altitude GF to the hypotenuse of 20
is equal to the shorter leg of 15 in the
larger triangle to the hypotenuse of 25
in other words in this smaller triangle
we have GF 2 its hypotenuse of 20 is
equal to in this larger triangle
the shorter side of 15 to the hypotenuse
of 25 so we can then solve the GF is
equal to 12
now what we'll do is we'll solve for C G
which is equal to 20 squared minus 12
squared and we take the square root of
the whole thing to get that C G is equal
to 16 now another way that we could do
this instead of using the Pythagorean
theorem is we could have noticed that C
GF is a four-time scaled version of a
special 3 4 5 right triangle but either
way we get that C G is equal to 16
this means that B G is equal to 25 minus
16 which is equal to 9 now the key to
this whole problem is to think inside
the box will draw F H to be
perpendicular to ad now notice that HD
is equal to G C which is equal to 16 now
in this triangle AED we've also created
some similar triangles by similar
triangles notice that the shorter leg of
the triangle - the longer leg is a
constant ratio so we have the following
in the smaller triangle the shorter leg
of H F - it's longer leg of 16 is equal
to in this triangle the shorter leg of
7/2 the longer leg of 24 we can use this
equation to solve that H F is equal to
14 over 3 so now HG is equal to 14 over
3 plus 12 which is equal to 50 over 3
and notice this is exactly equal to a B
because a B is equal to H G therefore a
B is equal to 50 over 3 I was stuck at
first but I kept trying and I did not
give up so sometimes the key is to think
inside of the box did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video these
math videos inspire and build confidence
for people around the world and they've
already gotten over a hundred million
views but the math metis never praise
these videos and they always spread
their negativity let's be extra positive
to cancel them out please help by
subscribing for free to get the new
most videos on this channel please also
watch and share all of my new decisions
videos that's the greatest way for
people to learn and discover this
channel you can also email me a puzzle
or math topic presh at mind your
decisions comm and if you so choose you
can support this channel financially by
checking out my books which are linked
in the description or supporting me on
patreon to earn exclusive rewards thanks
for watching and thanks for your support